Section two is titled research questions.
A designed study examines the tradeoffs between various non-functional
requirements, for example, space and time.
Each tradeoff can be expressed in the form of a question, such as,
how are execution times and
memory footprint effected as the amount of pre-processing computations vary?
The second section of your report lists such research questions.
Each question should be formulated in a neutral fashion with regard to the due,
dependent variables being measured and
also indicate what factors are being varied.
That is, the independent variables.
And each question should be numbered for later reference in your report